Let me ask you a question. And as you know, new, as always,
it's not worth searching for the answer on Google Wikipedia or anywhere else,
where would you say that the largest number of artworks in the world are
concentrated?
I'm sure most of you will think of the Louvre in Paris or the MoMA in New York,
or maybe even the British museum in London,
because we used to steal a lot of stuff.
Well, I'm sorry.
But no. Okay. Yes.
It's true that all of those museums house gigantic collections,
and then we'd also have to define exactly what we consider art and not,
but my visual public geeks, regardless of all these issues,
there is a veritable art truth that you've likely, never thought about.
The answer to the question we are asking ourselves at the beginning involves
careful consideration of Geneva in Switzerland. There,
we will find a very special place,
a place that houses one of the largest collections and certainly the greatest
amount of fine arts per square meter in the world.
And you know what the most surprising thing of all this is that neither you nor
I will ever be able to enjoy it.
Talking about the Freeport of Geneva. No, really, really,
we're not making a mistake. We are talking about to port and Geneva,
which despite having no see is one of the most important free ports in the
world. For those who aren't really familiar with them,
three ports are places with Alexa regulations and much less tax.
The idea is to make it easier to move goods founded in 1888.
The Geneva Freeport is located next to a large railway station where the dry
port for goods and far from what we might think it is neither an area restricted
to passage nor is it's a highly protected site surrounded by huge fences walls
and lots of security guards.
The truth is that the largest art collections in the world are in a couple of
not very large buildings that's located in your setting would probably go,
Nope, because this warehouse has so many works of art,
but not even the leaders of the Geneva.
Freeport are able to quantify numbers to give you an idea.
It is estimated that within its walls are stored thousands, tens of thousands,
possibly hundreds of thousands of works of art by such outstanding artists as
Leonardo da Vinci, fungal Renoir, El Greco among countless others. For example,
as believes that there are more than 1000 of Picasso's works deposited here.
In.
Fact, after an audit by swish officials in 2012,
it was revealed that there could be. And just remember,
this is just an estimate about 1 million,
200,000 works of art,
which would put it in the top three of world collections. And remember,
we're talking about a 2012 audit as believed at the current inventory could be
even greater to help you understand the magnitude we're talking about.
The national gallery in London has about 2,300 paintings and its
collection. And the moment in New York, almost 200,000 works of art of various.
So.
We're not only talking about the largest deposits of archived art on the whole
planet, but if we also take into account the quality,
the value of the work stored there, then with them,
you could possibly create the most impressive art gallery in the entire world.
So you probably want to know more about this secretive and stunning place.
What do you think about immersing yourself in a market as covert as the
international art market? Well,
you're in luck because that is exactly what we're going to talk about in this
video. Or let's get started.
The free port of Geneva shelter or hiding place.
Well, let's be honest.
The actual goods and figures handled engineer's report are unknown.
Even their own directors are not able to give concrete figures.
Do you know about this mysterious place? Is that amongst paintings, sculptures,
all types of antiques and pieces of art, of every variety,
the value of the works deposited here is simply unpleasantly priceless.
What's more, this space has become a good business for the Canton of Geneva.
I can't on that in addition to owning almost 90% of the shares of this Freeport
has income each year from this activity totaling more than $10 million,
but why degree collectors and great fortunes keep their collections and this
place and not any other, what advantages does it offer and why.
Is it called a port? I'm sure.
Exactly.
What many of you are asking yourself at this point and no wonder the traffic and
works of art is one of the most Etymotic business activities out there before we
go on a quick note,
don't think for a moment that Geneva is the only tax-free art bunker we can find
in the world.
Another of the most significant ones is close to Singapore airport.
I'm one of the most recent to open is in Delaware and the United States.
In other words, this concept is not unique.
Although Geneva is definitely the biggest,
Even though the Freeport of Geneva is only one of the 10 free ports and 245 free
zones that exist in Switzerland as an art bunker has become the greatest tax
Haven for large investors in this market.
One of the main advantages it offers is the possibility to make transactions
that is buy and sell works in the Freeport itself without paying any tax.
As long as goods do not leave the Freeport,
everything done is tax exempt is also tax-free to store an import art in
this place. And that's important because my friends,
the truth is that in most countries, Paris,
our taxes are between five and 15% are charged for the amputation of works.
Oh, of course.
Tax advantages.
Aren't the only thing that leads the world's biggest art collectors to use
Geneva.
Let's say there is something else fundamental that also has a lot to do with
Swiss financial culture. And that is discretion.
The Geneva free port is quite old. It is not an especially a glamorous place,
but this is not important. When you go to see a work of art,
it only means decent illumination and the certainty that it is well guarded,
the place is practical and central is a safe place to work and people value
discretion. Joel, Renee, Salyards sales director of fine art fund group.
Let's just say that they follow the old Swiss premise. Don't ask. Of course,
as you can imagine, that's not a policy that comes without
1994. For example,
antiquities looted from the Getty museum in Los Angeles were discovered in the
free port of Geneva in 1993, 200 ancient pieces stolen from Egypt were found.
And more recently our Romans, our caucus was found in 2010,
the disappearance of which had been reported in Turkey and in 2016,
two Etruscan sarcophaguses were returned to Italy.
These at other previous scandals,
forced reforms to bring in regulations to imports that target this Freeport and
Lang with those or similar zones within the rest of Switzerland. And this way,
and porters of works of art arriving in Geneva must know declare the name of the
owner, the origin and the value of the goods they store. And since 2009,
the Freeport of Geneva must also have an inventory of all of the items to be
found there. So what's the problem. Well,
many pieces not to mention most of the pieces that were stored there before 2009
have not been able to be inventors so only their owners knew that they are
there. And what the real value is.
In addition,
these kinds of places are not spared accusations about the role they play in the
global money laundering market.
Surprise.
According to many experts,
it is relatively easy to arrive with a good bundle of illicitly obtained bills
by a painting with them and resell it months later to get clean money without
even having to take the box out of the warehouse.
And as long as you don't sell it, believe me, your money is safe.
Of course not all art lovers are money laundering and my visual polar geeks,
apart from these issues,
the question we can ask ourselves as is this a shelter or a hiding place?
I'll leave you a video in the description related to this SU I think you might
find interest At this point.
How about we review what the international art market is, Lake on, what it is?
Why does so many great fortunes invested their money in art?
How much money does this market move annually?
What are the leading and emerging countries in the world? Arts trades.
If you want to know the answers to these questions, you had better stay tuned.
The art market safe value.
When we think of a value refuge to invest our money in,
what do we always think about real estate investments, stocks gold, maybe. Well,
for the really big fortunes art also plays a key role.
It's surprising as it might be.
The truth is that art trading has managed to overcome the hardest effects of the
great recession and position itself.
As one of the safest nonfinancial assets used by large fortunes to invest their
money. In fact,
as you can see in this graph,
the flow of money that has moved in the art market has remained quite stable.
Over the last decade,
we are talking about a market that moves more than $60 billion every year in art
sales, by the way,
can you imagine which countries are the main players and activity for this
market? Well, this time it's not Switzerland, it's basically two countries,
the United States and the United Kingdom together,
they account for more than 70% of experts.
Yes. Yeah. I know what you guys are thinking.
Haven't come this far and you're thinking to yourself, all right, grant,
but what does all this mean?
Why is art apparently so highly prized by great fortunes and seriously,
why is it.
Cold a port?
Well, just think about it for one moment. Every year that passes money,
loses value.
Businesses can be exposed to all kinds of technological and commercial
revolution. And if you don't believe me, just think about companies like,
I don't know, Kodak, Blackberry blockbuster. Remember those guys.
If you make loans, you may have to face delinquency.
And if you invest your money in fixed income and then a financial crisis occurs,
you may have many possibilities to lose much of your fortune,
but do you really think that one day the value of a Amani,
a Vanguard or a castle will depreciate,
do you think that signature art that is of renowned artists could lose.
The truth?
It says that to date,
there have been very few cases in which a famous work of art has been sold at a
lower price than it was previously purchased.
And that's exactly what encourages a large fortune to create their own art
collection.
And that's also what explains why real fortunes have been paid for some pieces,
for example, in 2017,
Leonardo da Vinci's Salvatore Mundi was sold in New York for a whopping
$450 million. No, really $450 million.
Yeah.
Let's take note here.
Two important things that we have to take into account when talking about art,
the art market is very closed because if you don't want to screw up,
you really have to know your stuff. And of course, as in any other market,
bubbles can be produced. And profitability is far from assured,
especially when you pay a lot for works of questionable.
In any case. The truth is that for decades,
the art market has been advancing favorably, monetary expansions, market,
interest rates, currency, devaluation, et cetera. For example,
take a look at this chart that shows us how the price of the most expensive
contemporary artwork sold since 1989 has evolved in 1989.
The most expensive piece of contemporary art was sold for just over $20 million.
And now the most expensive piece of art that was sold last year in 2019,
a sculpture of a steel rabbit was sold for a whopping $91 million.
That's 14.
Okay.
You said that let's take this a step further.
Can you imagine in which country this market has grown the most in recent years?
Well, I want you,
you're not gonna believe this and you really will not believe this because the
country I'm talking about is Argentina. No, really, really Argentina
by volume of exports of paintings and drawings.
Argentina ranks seventh in the world.
The land of the tango moved $483.5 million with this commercial
activity in 2019.
That's now pay attention to this number 1203% more
than the previous year. But if you really want to shock,
let's compare that to 2015.
The growth since then has been hold onto your butts.
56848 cent.
You might logically be asking yourself why is going on in Argentina?
Why is the art market there? Skyrocketing?
Let's take a look,
a surprising case of Argentina.
You said many times here before on visual politics,
Argentina is for it's bureaucracy, it's regulations, it's taxes and tires,
and a long et cetera of restrictions and impediments on an economic nature,
IE hellhole for a business and trade activity. However,
the case of arts seems like an exception and this area Argentine law is very
similar. And even freer than that, of many developed countries
After the amendment of law, two, four, six, three,
three on the international circulation of works of art in January, 2018,
Argentina,
further relaxed to procedures for exporting and importing works of arts.
Now only one export notice is needed for the work of artists alive or deceased
up to 50 years ago.
That is our exports are not subject to licensing or virtually any state control
in a country where everything absolutely everything is regulated in some way.
If we tell you that this procedure can be done completely online,
it gets even more interesting.
Right?
Not only that for works of art by artists who died more than 50 years ago,
you only need a license from the ministry of culture,
which can be obtained in less than 48 hours.
I wish everything was so easy in Argentina.
I wish anything was so easy anywhere that would certainly change a lot of things
and make life there a little bit easier.
The fact that is the Argentine that allows you, for example,
to arrive as a tourist by art,
and then take it out of the country as hand luggage on your plane without any
problem. In addition,
the law allows you to move art from abroad and enter the country without any
limitation in the case of fairs or exhibitions,
and whether they need to perform slow,
bureaucratic procedures that costs time and most importantly money. In fact,
when we're talking about art and many ways,
Argentina simply does not seem like Argentina
In this particular market would be so liberalized and deregulated. Well,
the official argument is that it is intended to promote to the circulation of
Argentine art around the world,
close quotes and thereby strengthened the national art.
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible].
As if the same premise would not justify doing exactly the same with the rest of
the sectors in the economy.
So why on earth is arts more important than I don't know, the gem industry,
for example, and this,
my visual politics nerds is precisely what doesn't feel right.
Could Argentina becoming more than a regional epicenter for the art market and
turning into something a little murkier.
It's just really not something that we can confirm 100% today,
but the suspicions are on the table,
especially considering how the rest of the Argentine economy works.
But we've brought you this far. It is your turn to note.
What is your opinion of the art market? Would you invest your money and it's,
and for the love of all that is Holy,
why is it called a port and a landlocked country?
Leave your answers in the comments. So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
If you did, please hit like to let us know that you did.
And don't forget to subscribe for all of our new videos,
which come out a couple of times a week.
You can also hit the little alarm button down there.
If you want to get notifications for when our videos are coming up on your phone
or device. Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They've provided all the vocals in this episode that were not my dulcet tunes.
Also, if you like podcasts, why don't check out my podcast,
it's called making Europe grants. Again, you can find it on Spotify, iTunes,
or wherever you get your podcasts as a comedic take on all politics and news.
A bunch of my comedy pounds.
Also this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.